¿Y si te dijera que existen billones
de pequeñas bacterias a tu alrededor?
Es así.
Los microorganismos llamados bacterias
fueron algunas de las primeras formas de vida
que aparecieron en la Tierra.
A pesar de constar sólo
de una célula,
su biomasa total es mayor que
la de todas las plantas y animales combinados.
Y viven prácticamente en todas partes:
en el suelo, en el agua,
en la mesa de la cocina, en tu piel,
incluso dentro de ti.
Que no cunda el pánico todavía.
A pesar de que tienes 10 veces
más células bacterianas dentro de ti
que células humanas en el cuerpo,
muchas de estas bacterias son inofensivas
o incluso beneficiosas,
ya que ayudan a la digestión y la inmunidad.
Pero hay manzanas podridas
que pueden causar infecciones peligrosas,
desde pequeños inconvenientes
a epidemias mortales.
Por suerte, hay medicamentos sorprendentes
listos para combatir infecciones bacterianas.
Sintetizados a partir de productos químicos
o de origen natural como el moho,
los antibióticos matan o neutralizan bacterias
interrumpiendo la síntesis de la pared celular
o interfiriendo en procesos vitales
como la síntesis de proteínas,
todo sin dañar las células humanas.
El despliegue de los antibióticos
durante el transcurso del siglo XX
ha hecho que muchas enfermedades
antes peligrosas sean de fácil tratamiento.
Pero hoy en día, más y más
nuestros antibióticos
son cada vez menos eficaces.
¿Ha salido algo mal
para que dejen de funcionar?
El problema no reside en los antibióticos,
sino en las bacterias que deben combatir.
La razón se encuentra en
la teoría de la selección natural de Darwin.
Como cualquier otro organismo,
las bacterias pueden sufrir mutaciones aleatorias.
Muchas de estas mutaciones son dañinas o inútiles,
pero de vez en cuando
una logra que su organismo
adquiera ventajas de supervivencia.
Y para una bacteria,
una mutación que es resistente
a un determinado antibiótico
le da una gran ventaja.
Como las bacterias no resistentes se eliminan,
lo que ocurre muy rápidamente
en ambientes ricos en antibióticos,
como los hospitales,
es que hay más espacio y recursos
para que prosperen los más resistentes
transmitiendo sólo los genes mutados
que contribuyen a hacerlo.
La reproducción no es
la única manera de hacerlo;
algunas pueden liberar su ADN tras morir
para que otras bacterias lo tomen,
mientras que otras utilizan
un método llamado conjugación,
conectándose a través de los pili
para compartir sus genes.
Con el tiempo, los genes resistentes proliferan,
creando cepas de bacterias superresistentes.
Así que, ¿cuánto tiempo nos queda
antes de que estas superbacterias tomen el relevo?
Bueno, con algunas bacterias
ya está pasando.
Por ejemplo, algunas variantes
de Staphylococcus aureus,
que causan de todo
desde infecciones de piel a neumonía y sepsis,
se han convertido en cepas SARM,
volviéndose resistentes a
antibióticos betalactámicos,
como la penicilina, la meticilina y oxacilina.
Gracias a un gen que sustituye la proteína
a la que los betalactámicos normalmente
se dirigen y unen
las cepas SARM puede seguir haciendo
sus paredes celulares sin impedimentos.
Otras superbacterias, como la salmonela,
incluso a veces producen
enzimas como los betalactámicos
que descomponen los antibióticos atacantes
antes de causar daños,
y el E. coli, un grupo diverso de bacterias
que contienen las cepas causantes
de diarrea e insuficiencia renal,
puede prevenir la función
de los antibióticos, como las quinolonas,
aniquilando activamente
a cualquier invasor que logre
entrar en la célula.
Pero hay buenas noticias.
Los científicos están trabajando
para estar un paso por delante de las bacterias,
y, si bien, el desarrollo de nuevos antibióticos
ha disminuido en los últimos años,
la OMS ha establecido como prioridad
el desarrollo de nuevos tratamientos.
Otros científicos investigan soluciones alternativas,
como la terapia de fago o el uso de vacunas
para prevenir las infecciones.
Lo más importante es frenar el uso excesivo
e innecesario de los antibióticos,
como para las infecciones de menores
que se curan por si solas,
así como cambiar prácticas médicas
para prevenir las infecciones hospitalarias,
lo que puede tener un impacto importante
conservando más bacterias no resistentes vivas
como competidoras de las cepas resistentes.
En la guerra contra las superbacterias,
desescalar a veces puede funcionar mejor
que la carrera evolutiva de armamentos.